um yeah I don't believe that acting on
um homosexuality
um is a sin at all
anybody that says the act of
homosexuality is not the same as a
kaffir
this app has been such a game changer to
me I've never been so consistent with my
Quran reading before I knew about qurani
and you can get quranly absolutely free
no credit cards for seven day free trial
what are you waiting for downloading
number one sisters and build a habit
with the qurani app right now
assalamualaikum guys and welcome to
another episode of Ali dawa smiling to
Jannah inshallah come on guys don't
forget to unsubscribe and dislike the
video that's right you know everyone
keep saying that I'm gonna say
unsubscribe don't commit and dislike how
about that yeah let's start the video
again let's do it let's watch it
inshallah so this is a video that I
watched and I was nearly pulling my hair
out uh due to one of the individuals
there a good Muslim woman wears a hijab
about one of the main reasons why I
disagreed is because of the statement a
good Muslim woman I think that you can
be a bad Muslim woman as well and wear
the hijab and then also the hijab is not
just limited to the headscarf it's how
you dress and how you carry yourself as
well where do you see in the Quran that
it requires a job so Allah says
it doesn't use the exact word hijab but
the word means headscarf yeah yeah that
makes sense I guess for me in how I've
read the Quran the translation that I
have the word is it required it should
that woman should cover their heads and
cover their chests and so that's that's
why I hesitate with saying that it's
it's an obligation because it's more of
us I would say should isn't most so the
first thing to understand is we don't
take our laws only from the Quran yeah
we have a hierarchy we've got the Quran
you've got foreign
[Music]
approach so to solely say that all the
Quran doesn't mention this is not good
enough you have to then refer to the
Sunnah then ijmar chaos Islam is not
just based upon the Quran so that's a
fundamental mistake that um that view
doesn't take into consideration yeah and
she was like oh where does it say that
and it brings evidence and he goes okay
well that's good she's taking it but
then I don't know about why would she
not it's as if she had something and it
just backfired like okay he knew what he
was talking about which the brother
didn't know what he was talking about
and she was like okay it could just be
her tone the benefit of the dot that she
just wants him to kind of uh give the
proof but then I think why would you do
that it might be for the purpose of the
video knowing it's a non-muslim audience
kind of okay all right all right no
problem just had the prompt to literally
I mean I consider myself a good Muslim
alhamdulillah but um I don't wear the
hijab obviously even if the Quran
doesn't specifically say that this is
required the interpretation of the Quran
has said that it is required and I do
believe that I know it seems kind of
contradicting that I'm a conservative
Muslim and I don't wear the hijab I just
I don't think I'm ready to kind of wear
the hijab yet I want to wear the hijab I
need to wear the hijab hola you know
it's so profound bro she doesn't wear
the hijab yeah and look at her mentality
bro and then you've got someone on the
other side liberal who got some sort of
hijab one or the one within the cup who
believes she's liberal yeah probably
just shows you again bro do not to judge
people from the outer garment
well liable she doesn't wear hijab and
is abiding yep that's what Allah says
even look I'm not wearing it yeah well
like I believe she's 100 times better
than the one who's questioning like oh
is it does it you know
acting on homosexuality is a sin
um I believe that acting on
homosexuality is a sin if especially
like if you were expressing sexual
desire because that should take place
between a man and a woman under the
sanction of marriage so that is the
reason why I do feel as though it is a
sin and it's uh pretty clear in the
Quran says
he said do you guys prefer men over
women when he's talking to the people of
Loot and the prophet peace be upon him
he says that one of the the biggest
problems for the ummah is the sin of
loot or the people of Luth again we
could just all agree you know this is
not our personal opinion or anything
that's in another day when it comes to
religion or personal opinion doesn't
matter right it doesn't matter this is
what God ordained for us you know this
is the the natural way what if you start
diving in and wanting whatever we want
it just where does it end at that point
when is it is going to come to incest
next for instance in America or in the
west homosexuality 30 years ago wasn't
accepted you preached my brother I know
it's acceptable this is the liberal idea
right
shifts it ships based on the time we
don't shift in in our religion
um yeah I don't believe that acting on
homosexuality
um is a sin at all um there's so much to
get into in the story of prophet itself
you see that
that they weren't condemned because they
the people the prophet were coming to to
his house to have sex with the men who
were disguised as Angels but for you can
look at it as a condemnation of of rape
and and abuse itself and mistreatment of
strangers and the Quran verse that you
cited as well within that verse Allah
uses the prefix Al which is and there's
interpretations that exist that say that
specifically is talking about those men
specifically who leave those women
specifically so meaning that those men
who did that had wives that they left to
go rape these or try to attempt to rape
these um guests in an attempt to bring
humiliation upon the prophet and to um
to uh sorry I'm getting a little
emotional no it's not emotional she's
not she's not she's not getting
emotional you can see from a tone voice
she has
um heard this story yeah it's a story by
the way it's a made-up story yeah from
God knows who and she is so
nerve-wracked because it's a
nerve-wracking moment for her because
it's the first time she can use that
kind of evidence and now she's thinking
she's making some kind of point and
realizing that she has no point you can
see it's not emotional she's not
emotional she's it's a nerve-wracking
moment for her to get it because she
knows what were you talking about it was
for that specific person who are you I
told you who are you Allah
which uh
the way she stretched the story
the the question is is she uh alusi the
famous uh Quran
exegete no because he's of the opinion
all of these are Lucy
all the quranic
are unanimous that homosexual this is
referring to homosexuality the act of
homosexuality and homosexuality is a sin
it's not referring to rape none of them
of a Serene the major mufaserin say this
this is not an opinion if there was
leeway here and there there is no leeway
there is unanimity on this point that
this is referring to a homosexual act
and that homosexual Act is Haram it is
forbidden and then again it's because
certain people just rely on the Quran
that's why we said it's a four-pronged
approach you then go on the Hadith the
dhirmity Hadith actually I don't know
how clear-cut you can make it put in
your private part in the anus of a man
and a woman
is not permitted Allah doesn't even look
at that person that's the Hadith exactly
so this is you can't this is something
you can't even do with your wife
which is permissible for you yeah and
you can't and by the way you can be
Muslim and gay in the context of It's a
Sin you can someone could be an
adulterer he's a Muslim some couldn't be
a person an alcoholic yeah somebody can
be a murderer being Muslim is those acts
do not take out the fault of Islam
that's not what we're talking about and
I've had many discussions with
homosexuals on this matter the point is
where you're trying to make it
permissible that's Bill yes that's
anyone meaning there is no differences
different opinion period yeah that to
say that the act of homosexuality is not
a sin yeah and let's listen to I'll go
further
there's different interpretations of the
story of prophet one interpretation is
that it's about homosexuality and there
are other interpretations throughout
history that says it wasn't about
homosexuality but for some reason the
interpretation that it is condemning
homosexuality is the dominant narrative
and I think that narrative seriously
needs to be contended with because we're
saying that you know being homosexual
being homosexual or being bisexual or
being anything other than heterosexual
is a sin but Allah creates you like that
Allah creates people who are intersex
like intersex people exist in this world
and so I think there's a lot of
different
she's saying Allah created those pieces
so okay well Allah magic down
which is something that takes you at the
fold of Islam the act of homosexuality
doesn't take you the full of Islam but
involving in can take you out the fold
of Islam yeah so now they were sent down
and the angels told them we are sent
down as a test what are you going to say
don't say
[Music]
did Allah
what kind of justification is this you
can't use this justification of we are
created like this that's fine I spoke to
a homosexual
is a brother who had these Tendencies
and bro his attitude was totally
different I submit to Allah this is how
yes I have this information but I will
fight it yeah married couple they'll be
spending time you know um with their
family children I get to spend time with
Allah
wow you can see how you can view it also
so there are people like that out there
so all we're just saying is my dear
sister I'm not trying to be harsh on you
but please don't come and try to change
the religion with all due respect look
you want to be like that at least come
and say it's Haram like that sister who
when it came to the hijab he said I
don't wear it but this one Allah said at
least be honest this is what annoys me
if you make something that's Haram Halal
or you make something that's Halal Haram
that's that that's a problem bro that's
ichma anybody that says the act of
homosexuality is not the same as a cafe
Cafe I'm not talking about her I'm
talking anybody that comes and says Act
of homosexuality is not a sin you are a
cafe
it's as simple as that because you are
doing is
said to one of the Companions and he was
a Jew he said did you not used to
worships
he said did you not used to uh when they
used to make something
Halal he said yeah he said that's how
you made them you you know that's how
you made them you know the form of
worship because you're taking what
they're saying like Allah said and
you're here with no qualifications don't
you respect yeah and you you are you are
nervous or something came on you that
you can't even speak properly
subhanallah and you are there trying to
make these verdicts oh the the general
view needs to be questioned no you need
to be questioned just because you feel
like in today's time it's a norm okay no
problem if you have these Tendencies
we're not saying to you these Tendencies
take out the fall of Islam you can be a
Muslim but don't come and see it's not a
sin because that takes all the food of
Islam yeah
um and when you are making points like
this and you're saying an interpretation
who's saying this and where's this
interpretation the brothers when they
spoke they gave evidence from the Quran
yes you're saying oh there's anything
because I've just given you all the main
names that are referred to say where's
the evidence for this that the United
there is no evidence for this it's very
weak it's conjecture it's not
peer-reviewed study that says that you
are born gay that's just it's completely
false and she hasn't bought anything to
the table again she just started getting
emotional she Square herself and she
she's actually bought nothing of
credibility there's nothing that you can
actually take from what she said and
there's nothing that's actually got me
thinking Hmm I need to look into this or
exactly or that as well yeah so being
bro there are certain people that have
inclinations towards animals towards
small children towards their dead bodies
no problem incense yeah necrophilia
incest yeah can you can you allow them
if they came and said you look at me go
to this woman this woman and tell her
that um I have if a man came and said
I've been conditioned necrophilia I like
um having interviews with dead people or
in
what would you say what would you say
you say uh uh you disgusting person
why are you saying that I thought Love
Is Love I thought they're born like this
they can come and make that argument I
am created like I have these desires
that's what Allah says have you seen the
one who takes his desire as his illah as
his God you know what that means we as
human beings we can go to all kinds of
lengths of all kinds of stuff yeah okay
but the thing is what it's about taming
and it's about for the sake of Allah and
Allah says if you fear me I will give
you a way out from places you can never
imagine you know what that means that
guy that I spoke to in the Park yeah and
I put the video there that I said to him
once you put your trust in Allah there
is nothing that Allah cannot get you out
of even if you're born with certain
Tendencies yeah Allah
spinal tala can get you out and you will
have the pleasure of this life you might
say yeah but I can't get married Allah
will put you in a situation where he
will get you out but put your trust in
him not taking your own desires as your
lord it's like we're told to control
ourselves we have a tendency to cross a
red light we have a tendency to you know
um Ogle uh women or whatnot as human
beings if somebody's shaking the bits
and Bobs about you're naturally gonna
look but you have to avert your gaze you
can't touch this this control involved
in every aspect and any aspect of life
we're naturally inclined not to wait
like our body is inclined towards rest
but we have to go to work you can't use
this argument that oh we're born like
this it's not a act which is beneficial
and conducive
um to the procreation of life or to to
other things as well
exactly and I mean in a nutshell that's
all I all I'm going to say
um that look against the star you can be
a Muslim but don't compensate it's not a
sin yeah you might feel strong about it
all we're just seeing is
and don't cross that line please okay we
as a Muslims as Islam Islam accepts you
with your sins even if they reach the
skies and no I would say to the sister
that she needs to speak to somebody of
knowledge and possibly yes 100 I'm so
sorry you know your statements are
statements that take one at the fold of
Islam again I'm just talking generally
here please be careful and if you see it
Allah destroyed many nations because of
Sheikh the common look is the only
generation was
[ __ ] is not mentioned like as much yet
yeah and they will destroy just for the
ACT yeah there was a sahaba who said if
he said if I if someone didn't come and
told me that people do this acting who's
not in a million years I think this
exists
and that's all like I mean that's all I
want to say nothing else
um and my dear sister please we want the
best for you
accept it as a sin it's a sin no problem
we're not saying you are evil all we're
seeing is accepted as a sin like many
people commit sins and just say it's a
sin I ask Allah to help me and I'm
working that's all we're seeing